die fußballwelt in trauer nach
argentinischen medienberichten ist
fußball legende diego maradona im alter
von 60 jahren gestorben
demnach soll maradona in seinem haus
integre einen herz kreislauf stillstand
erlitten haben der weltmeister von 1986
war am 2 november in eine privatklinik
in buenos aires eingeliefert worden
bei einer untersuchung wurde ein
blutgerinnsel im gehirn entdeckt dass
sie ihm einen tag später entfernt wurde
nach der erfolgreichen op wurde maradona
am 11 november entlassen und sollte sich
integre von dem eingriff erholen
nur 14 tage später folgte die schock
nachricht für die fans weltweit mit
maradona verliert der fußball einen der
größten stars aller zeiten
und im grunde
für argentinien machte das mittelfeld
genie zwischen 1977 und 1994 insgesamt
91 länderspiele und 34 tore
1986 führte er sein land als kapitän zum
wm titel erhielt die auszeichnung zum
besten spieler des turniers
[Applaus]
legendär dabei das viertelfinale gegen
england 2 zu 1 maradona erzielte beide
tore
das erste davon irregulär mit der hand
über den kopf später sagte er über den
treffer es war der kopf maradonas und
die hand gottes das zweite tor bei dem
er mit einem 60 meter solo die komplette
englische hintermannschaft aus trippelte
wurde 2002 zum tor des jahrhunderts
gewählt
später wechselte maradona zum ssc neapel
wo er sich in den folgenden sieben
jahren unsterblich machte aber schon in
neapel zeigt sich maradonas hang zum
exzessiven leben er lässt sich von der
kamera mit kokain und prostituierten
versorgen maradona fiel auch danach
immer wieder durch skandale auf der
starfußballer wurde sechsmal zu
südamerikas fußballer des jahres und
viermal zu argentiniens fußballer des
jahres gewählt
zuletzt war maradona coach des
argentinischen erstligisten gymnasiasten
emana plata sein vertrag lief noch bis
zum ende der saison doch wegen einiger
gesundheitlicher probleme konnte er
zuletzt kaum noch an der seitenlinie
stehen
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier und vergesst bitte nicht
unseren kanal zu abonnieren